[Music]
elizabeth starts this hour in san
antonio hi elizabeth how are you
hi i'm doing great
um
so what's going on and i actually wish i
was calling to say to do my debt free
scream i've been wanting to do that for
a long time
uh we are debt-free the house is paid
off the cars are paid off everything
um i am working full-time and a student
also and then
in about a year i'll go full time
where i won't work also for nursing
and my husband he works full-time he's
phd scientist
and then we have a 18 year old son who
has moved out and started a business he
didn't want to go to college
how can we help today
okay just wanted to lay the foundation
so
we've got everything paid off and my
husband wants to buy an all-electric
vehicle and we were going to um save up
for it to pay cash
and currently we have two prius that are
um not the plug-in kind
and
suddenly now today he wants to go
purchase it he feels like there's a
sudden need that we need to do it now
because of everything that's going on in
the world and that
this is the time and not wait so we're
also cash flow in my school and so we do
have sorry what's going on in the world
that demands that you get a plug-in
vehicle today i missed i didn't watch
the news this morning
so he feels like we um
like
potentially in the future
yeah yeah and that we would be better
off getting it now that just uh
are you telling me the guy has a phd and
he truly believes there's going to be no
gasoline
no there's not no gas no just okay so
we're both very frugal and we um
so you know what is going on in the
world
that demands that you buy an electric
vehicle you said he think with all
that's going on in the world what the
crap does that mean
well that the demand for electric
vehicles is going up and that they are
harder and harder to get and there's a
long wait list for you know all the ones
that are on the market right now
um and in other words i want an electric
vehicle
and i don't want to wait until i don't
want to wait and so i'm just now right
now i'm making up crap worry about okay
so what's your household income
so our household income is about 155.
he makes 113 i make about 43. okay and
what are you gonna what are you buying
what kind of a car is he wanting like a
tesla
um so
we're between the dw uh id4
the bolt was just recalled on friday so
we can't get that one which was much
less expensive
and then our only other option really is
the tesla
okay
so let me help you with the math to
start with
you can drive that freaking tesla to the
moon and back
and mathematically you will never
justify
how much more you've spent on the tesla
than you're paying off than you than the
value of your prius
you know how much time it's going to
take you to recoup 45 000
in electric and gas savings
the rest of your freaking life
okay
so let me just tell you mathematically
this is asinine that we're using the
idea that we're saving money because
we're frugal to get an electric car
now if you want to go get a tesla
fine go get you a tesla but pay cash for
it
but you don't you don't say oh
everything that's going on in the world
and we're frugal people because both of
those things are stupid but statements
because they don't have anything to do
with reality okay that you know
everything that's going on in the world
they're making teslas you can get a
tesla i mean there's not
you know and they're not going to be
like not able to get one and if you're
not able to get one like a delorean
that means you didn't want one because
they went broke okay
and elon didn't make it you know but um
but the uh but if you get one which is
fine i got several friends that have
bought them um i prefer a motor but
that's okay get you one it gets you a
battery it's okay and so but but the
point is you guys make enough money to
pay cash for a sixty thousand dollar car
here's what i think in cash i knew where
you buy it
when
when our brains go to fight or flight
when we're scared
it actually has a cool bypass mechanism
in your brain that turns off your
critical thinking
part of your of your brain
because you it didn't want you sitting
at the front of a cave wondering is that
a nice tiger or is that a fluffy one a
petting tiger it just wanted you to run
or to grab a stick and go to war because
if if it happened to be a mean tiger and
you thought it was a nice one you were
going to be dead right and so it's a
cool little feature our brains have
where it trades
it trades speed for accuracy close
enough
and it sounds like you've got a husband
who loves you loves your kids
and is consuming
24 7 365 news
and he's worked himself up in a panic
and he's sitting there at home and at
home and at home and what i need to do i
need to do something and do something
and he can go down a rabbit hole that's
going to shoot him out one media
slide that's going to tell him we're
going to be at oil it's going to be 111
a gallon it's going to be this and that
and then he's comes up with a solution
that makes no mathematical sense
rational sense climates it makes no
sense but it feels like it's the right
thing to do
and what i need that guy to do is to
close the devices
get connected to a human being
go sit down and tell somebody i'm
terrified and i'm about to make a wild
decision that doesn't make any
mathematical sense does it make any
rational sense
that i'm i'm not i'm not it's contrary
to my goals it's it's not where i want
to be the goals the goals of this family
have been to become and be debt free and
out of left field mr phd dumps into the
middle and goes ah
we gotta finance a tesla i'm gonna buy a
depreciation computer and everything
that's going on in the world and it's
like you're right his brain is
completely shut down so let's go to the
devoid of critical let's go to the end
result the end thing here let's say
there we do run out of gas dave or the
gas becomes 100
i'm just having fun for a second it's
not fun and it does
having an electric car will be the your
neighbors will line up in your driveway
to shoot you if you're the only electric
car
so the world that you are predicting
that you're going to solve for is not
going to look like the world you have
now plus you have electric car so it's
okay that when i panicked i bought
bullets
i'm not saying that's okay
i'm saying that
yeah whatever yes way to go dave so what
i'm saying is when you solve for chaos
you're solving an improbable math
problem
right so what does that mean it means
you're not okay yeah your husband's spun
out yeah and he needs to put the
computer down put the debit card down
and go sit down and talk to somebody
he's not okay or get some friends in his
life this is this is yeah
stop the panic it's not the madness
and i'm just shaming him straight up for
his panicking
i mean for his lack of critical thinking
skills because it's just stop stop just
silly what's up
everything that's going on in the world
a drama queen you know come on seriously
this is the ramsey show